in south carolina this morning a once
prominent and powerful lawyer is charged
with the murders of his wife and
19-year-old son
alex murdoch was indicted yesterday more
than a year after his wife and son were
found shot to death at the family's
estate the disgraced lawyer was already
in jail at the time facing charges in an
attempted suicide and money fraud scheme
he's also accused of stealing more than
eight million dollars from clients and
his own family's law firm murdoch's
license to practice law was taken away
this week nikki batista is reporting on
this story for 48 hours
what is your name my name is alex
murdock on the night of june 7 2021 alex
murdoch told
911 dispatchers he found his wife and
22-year-old son unresponsive on their
sprawling south carolina estate my wife
murdock claimed he was visiting his ill
father in the hospital the night of the
murders but sources told digital news
site fits news that blood spatter was
found on murdoch's clothes the murder
indictment alleges murdoch shot his
52-year-old wife maggie murdock with a
rifle and his son paul with a shotgun i
tracked down murdoch's lawyer in
september
they didn't have any insurance they did
not have no insurance
no insurance
in a statement to cbs news murdock's
lawyer said alex wants everyone to know
that he did not have anything to do with
the murders of maggie and paul and that
alex did not have any motive
the 54 year old has been in a south
carolina jail since october after he
admitted to an attempted suicide scheme
days after his family's legendary law
firm accused him of stealing millions
from clients prosecutors say murdoch
hired this man 61 year old curtis smith
to shoot him in the head with hopes of
leaving a 10 million dollar insurance
windfall to his surviving son
smith says murdoch was like a brother to
him so when murdoch called smith
claiming to need help he says he didn't
think twice before heading to meet him
when smith arrived on a stretch of road
he says murdoch emerged from his car
holding a gun he's been there
like this
he said yeah you got take care of this i
said
well i can't do it
he told me he turned his head i just
grabbed his arm put it behind his head
to the gun for me smith claims during
that struggle the gun went off then he
disposed of the weapon yeah he wanted me
to kill him to make it look like a
suicide
manhattan
both alex murdoch and curtis smith were
charged in that suicide scheme there's
more in 2018 murdoch's housekeeper
gloria satterfield died at his house
after according to murdoch she fell down
the stairs murdoch told her children to
sue him for insurance money they did but
according to prosecutors murdoch
pocketed the settlement of more than
four million dollars no autopsy was ever
done just over two weeks ago
investigators asked satterfield's
family's permission to exhume her body
as they take a closer look at her death
boy nikki this has been a bizarre story
from the very beginning from that 9-1-1
call where he had such anguish in his
voice showing him about his wife and son
and now to hear that he's been charged
but what can you tell us about paul the
son who was killed he was also involved
in legal trouble wasn't he yes there was
a cloud building around the murdoch
family in 2019 paul murdoch was driving
his family's boat it crashed a 19 year
old woman mallory beach died he was
charged with voting under the influence
but what's interesting what we dive into
in 48 hours is alex murdoch's behavior
in the days after that crash
in what looks like an effort to protect
his family's name so we have those
details
so many twists and turns it's really
kind of hard to follow but people are
dead more swiss interns than a hollywood
movie alex murdoch now has more than 80
felony counts he faces life
up to life in prison and possibly the
death penalty more twists and turns on
highway moving more charges than a whole
gang of two yeah exactly
amazing yeah that's a lot of allegations
thank you nikki and you can see nikki's
report it's called the murdoch mysteries
on 48 hours that's tomorrow night at 10
9 central right here on cbs and on
paramount plus